I joined the 1/6 one project just for
more information as far as in what else
there are other options to do and to try
something different from being doing the
same thing for 20 odd years with my
father has seen an opportunity to get
someone else's opinion and have a
different perspective on Gronk a quark
machine has been a really good
experience Shannon's been really open to
the recommendations and he's been keen
to understand why we're doing what we're
doing and he's grasp the concepts really
well the main specific change that we've
made by being in the project is dropping
nitrogen levels so far it's been really
good haven't had any problems that we've
conceived by dropping nitrogen rates
quite happy looking forward to what's
going on especially from a financial
point of view as well as anything else
we went through what soil samples he had
them and we put together a nutrient
programme based on just matching up with
the the soils and the nutrients the
nutrient management plane is what we
decide on what fertilizer goes on all
our crops there we 100% follow what's
been recommended it's very easy to
follow doesn't require us to look any
further into because they're all the
rates and everything John's already put
down for us say yeah there's no further
research needed it's all available for
us right there and then on the one sheet
of paper the success of our p16 one is
really around being our able to tailor
the recommendations and present them
back to the growers so that they any
doubts about what they're trying to do
is being removed so they can understand
the recommendations are suited best
practice for their particular farm and
then they're quite happy to move forward
and put them into place working with
John and using the nutrient management
plan it's just a reassurance from
someone else's opinion and it's he's
been very straightforward and easy to
understand what he's trying to
accomplish and the reasons for doing
what we plan on doing so far what I've
learned from being in the project that
you don't need as
amount of nitrogen as the sponsor
thought and after the first year we've
had the best crop we've had in 50 years
this project I would highly recommend to
other people that are willing to try and
get out there and just for patrol path
because yeah well I've seen no
repercussions of drawing it in in the
bottom line is it saved us money so far
[Music]